I throw up so hard that I'm sore the
next day though like when I throw up
it's not like like I've seen people have
peaceful throws like just like this I'm
like hey welcome back to another super
fun episode of the careful boys and
today big round of applause we have
silent Mike in the building come on baby
always it's a good time I feel like you
guys used to not like me here now I feel
like so welcome when did we not like you
I don't know I'm not getting a round of
a [__] Applause to show up be like
Mike's here again like
we got to develop a relationship you
can't just here since 2012 I wasn't here
with you and the first time I thought
you said 2022 no like 2012 2013 I think
bro yeah that's why I was like I I
thought that we we knew him way long it
was just a round of applause we're not
making the whole [__] video about you
all right here we
go yeah that was weird that was weird
hey can you just rela opportunity all
right when you're sick all right what
are some things that you eat drink watch
Etc what are your things that you do to
get comfortable or better what's your
thing straight to bed what kind of I
don't [__] around what are you talking
about any kind of stomach
fluck like real sick sick like sick from
the dick or is it the flu sick from the
dick always straight to it if I'm pretty
sick I'm going straight to bed because
I'm going kill it yeah if you like are
kind of sick and you keep trying to like
oh I'll tough it out tough it out you're
going to be sick for a week it prolongs
it yeah I'm trying to kill this [__]
sleep I go straight to bed and then I
don't think the foods actually help but
I do have some [__] I'll eat like an aai
bowl or a smoothie I don't think that's
actually doing even if you got a cold
you're going for like cold stuff
probably it's got a bunch of vitamins
and [__] and like normally you don't
have a huge appetite when you're sick
and that stuff's easy to eat yeah and
it's sweet I drink a lot of water yeah
water Gatorades what about soup ginger
ale [__] you do soups I don't like soup
I love soup who doesn't like soup
especially when you're sick get some f
action soup obviously eating soup I just
don't like soup I make it myself you
what the you know what the secret is
when you're sick you go
Fu you go Chien chicken chicken Fu chck
like what the fuckick chicken noodle
soup he no he said a word that I don't
think we're allowed to say f f yeah like
that is that I did I say it right I know
pretty good right thank you I love a
chicken nudy soup you got to go chicken
NY with you what I do when it when I'm
even pre sick so even when I start
feeling like what the [__] is that
[__] itchy nose is that allergies and
if I take allergy med Med and my nose is
still itchy then I know okay it's no
longer allergies it's like [__] pre
sickness the first thing I do is when I
go home I either fill up a bathtub like
super hot with water or I go to a sauna
and I just do that for like 30 minutes
cuz like this is my bro science but you
know how like the reason why you have a
fever is because trying to burn [__]
yeah cuz the viruses and bacteria
they're adapted to your 98° temperature
so when you have a fever it's your
body's way of elevating the temperature
and zapping them so I'm like let me just
zap them harder yeah on my own so I go
into a SAA I go into [__] hot hot tub
and I [__] try to kill the
[__] then I make I make like
ginger honey lemon soup and then I just
try to I I do like the silent mic method
where I try to knock out so I can make
it as short as possible so I can get
over it versus trying to like tough it
out but then it ends up being like a two
we cold or some [__] all my sicknesses
like they like they they're done in like
48 hours cuz of that I just sleep it
through like crazy I just [__] drink
a ton of liquids I haven't been sick
since 2021 what's the uh [__] uh feda
fever starve a cold you ever heard that
oh yeah yeah yeah feed the fever starve
the cold AKA you always want to be warm
if it's if you have a cold you don't let
yourself stay cold so you like stay warm
if you have a fever and you're hot you
feed that fever and you stay hot so it's
always about staying hot I don't know
what the hell it means but I have a I
have a special drink I now I get I guess
I thought I had to do with food
well why you eating [__] cold deid
and [__] I don't know because I like
them that's why I was questioning for
some reason when I'm sick too I eat a
bunch of junk food well there's probably
a lot of vitamins and the [__] fruits
right so then your your body's like I
want some vitamin C I don't really
believe that [__] either as Bart knows
I'm pretty anti like everything but like
when I'm sick I'll slam a [__] ton of
vitamins for no reason yeah all like
[__] Postmates like ginger shot yeah
I'll just play games with my own head
even though I don't believe it but
Ginger does make you feel better though
cuz it just like Burns Burns you like a
[__] it's burning something
ginger tea is pretty fast you have a
drink you I do oh yeah it's called Jesus
Juice all right I need that okay it's
hibiscus it's honey it's lemon and you
boil a whole [__] thing of Ginger
it's spicy as hell that sounds like you
chop up the ginger and you boil a living
life out of it so it's all
juster the ginger finds Jesus in that
moment and I swear to God you drink that
[__] and then you taste the passion of
of Christ dude specifically Jesus I
don't really like medicine either but
I'll do like a like put myself in a
NyQuil coma n regardless of the sickness
I'll put at like 9:00 a.m. or 900 p.m.
and then try to sleep like 9: to 9 yeah
9 to: I'll try I can't sleep that much
anymore 7 hours and I'm up that's why
you need nil but then when I'm sick I
could do a good 10 nil donkey sleep is a
thing I get five hours I can only do
five hours I can only do [__] five
hours what about with nightquil too oh
nightquil knocks me the [__] out yeah
nqu is the [__] that's J honestly
NyQuil is that's it end the video dude
just yeah you sleep the whole time just
sleep bro I felt like this last night I
felt like I was getting sick all week
and I I had to and I was getting like 4
hours every night of sleep oh no and
then last night I actually got some
sleep and I feel so much better today I
thought I was going to have a cold I
thought I was going to be [__] up
sometimes I wish I could get sick again
because I miss thlu you can still have
some nah thlu while you're sober I mean
not sober thlu when you're not sick it's
not the same it feels better when you're
not comfortable and then you drink THU
slip dude she get Hammer drug just
slaming therapist with like drug Taco
Bell at 2
a.m. theru while you're alone I mean
when you're at a party yeah therap Le
drunk and you're out of alcohol so you
switch to that's some degenerate [__]
dude yo that [__] will probably hit
though yeah the scissor did you know
they had to recall theru back in the day
and then change the formula cuz they had
some illegal [__] in there I mean even I
think California can't even get like
real psea fed really it's like an Off
chemical yeah you can't first of all
psea fedit cuz I think you make like
meth speed or some [__] from it my mom
complains about it all the [__] time
my sister lives in Oregon she sends us
real susea fed yeah
exactly cuz they used to have like the
real [__] you could knock out a coal
with it real quick but then people start
making meth with it [__] meth heads
dude ruining everything the the minute
my sleep goes down the drain that's like
the first thing that happens is I get
sick if I have like yeah if I have like
let's say three or 4 days like if I'm
traveling or I'm not getting enough
sleep almost immediately I'll get sick
the next week I'm the same way when I
used to travel for work when I worked
with a different company and I would
have to work crazy ass hours uh i'
literally get like sick as [__] every
time I came home like bad like a bad flu
for 3 Days fever 103 travel will [__]
you up man I used to
mess with your sleep cycle and that it's
just sleep dude I swear to God Co made
me like invulnerable to any sickness now
I haven't been sick either since me too
maybe Co was a great thing maybe that
was the last thing that got me sick I
might get like a little tickle here
there or think that something's going to
happen and I'm fine I haven't had like a
virus or a cold but I've had like I ate
like bad [__] and then yeah diarrhea or
whatever vom that's always on the table
dud yeah that's may be worse F food
poisoning is the ab I've only had real
food poisoning like once where it's just
coming out of every hole just once you
lucky son of a [__] Taco Bell bro F PO
is one of the best [__] diets of like
10 lb in 3 days you get abs you're
guaranteed ABS after it's [__] sick I
hate it but what if I'm like kind of
chubby in that season you're just
praying there's a part of me your meat
out before you cook it yeah you know do
Taco Bell did it to me and throwing up I
don't know if I thrown up since like
throwing up is one of the worst things
on the planet I could do like a fever
but like throwing up dude I kind of like
throwing up cuz it feels good after
feels great never that's junk throwing
up oh no I'm thinking of like you had
something bad yeah I had a I had this um
food truck burrito one time that was
insane I like broke out in hives dude it
was [__] crazy I had to call in a
sick from work the next day it was like
15 years ago and like I was like
shivering and bed and [__] like I had
the real deal and that felt good no
throwing it up throwing it up people say
that about like too much beer and [__]
and then throwing up but I've never
really done that either when you're full
in your throw yeah it's easy to think I
mean once you get past the pain of that
short moment afterwards especially when
you're like too drunk and then you throw
up and then suddenly you're like
coherent there's part of you that's hey
give me a shot yeah give me he's back
I'm in the game and then like 12 minutes
later I throw up so hard that I'm sore
the next day though like when I throw up
it's not like like I seen people have
peaceful thrs like just like this I'm
like and I can't even it's that [__]
loud I can't even control it and the
next day I'm like oh [__] my [__]
diaphragm what the [__] well when it's
like coming you like start drooling I
feel like I'm like a Rabbid dog and I
get like a mini panic attack like oh
here here we go start crying and then
you look up and your eyes are blood shot
that freaks me out I've never had a
peaceful one I've seen peaceful ones too
our buddies drinking cuz I don't drink
that much I've had the Buddies like yo
hold on bro then they're like right back
in just water
Legend Never mine is like flexing every
bone your buddy's my buddy now all those
guys they they know they know it's
coming it's like routine I hate that
that's crazy you said uh sick uh like
what you watch too I love uh this is a
tangent side kind of but being sick the
one good thing and shitty weather oh
yeah getting on a couch and watching
like movie marathons is one my favorite
sweat and if I'm sick or that the
weather's bad it like calms my
entrepreneur brain like oh we're we're
supposed to do this like don't feel
guilty for being lazy right now it's
raining like is telling you to chill
yeah so like that's the one time I feel
like it actually relax like all right
I'm supposed to be about today that's
true that's it feels like the crops are
just you can't deal with the season
wrong to work dude in Vegas cuz like we
get some hardcore weather sometimes
it'll like be hailing or something bro
what about that last flood I was there
for that holy [__] well the best thing
about that too is they're always like
Vegas is flooded and I'm like the link
is flooded nothing's [__] flooded not
where we're at the link was built like
in the shittiest place where like all
that water goes those videos do look
crazy it looks like the universal tour
when the fake blood comes people walking
like I'm like where the [__] are you
Swedish there's Swedish people just
trying to gamble for the first time and
they're walking across a [__] the Red
River my mom calls me I'll make sure
that she sees me on FaceTime like
outside like it's like fine Mom what are
you talking about she thinks I'm in a
canoe or something just cuz the link is
for it's always the link okay it's not
us but yeah
um huh that [__] no cuz it's a great
it's a great little excuse like if it's
Halen or some [__] it's a great little
excuse to be like I can't go
anywhere turn on some TV I like that
watch a Star Wars movie or some [__] Bro
Lord of the Rings Lord of the Rings Star
Wars and Harry Potter cuz they're just
you can't miss yeah you can't miss
somehow I'm closer to you all of a
sudden what the [__] that's the most
excited he's been I'm also further from
both of you now I don't okay this
[__] I don't think has seen Star
Wars I don't even [__] think you know
the difference between that and Star
Trek or Harry Potter huh wait not even
one of them oh [__] I know for a fact he
doesn't those three are like which the
OG uh obviously the OG's are the best
but I I'm I like young Anakin bro I like
a little pod racing and then the whole
Hobbit series is actually really good
yeah Clone Wars War clone wars is a good
time with it Lord of the Rings obviously
bangs top to bottom and Harry Potter too
what's your favorite Lord of the Ring
favorite Lord I mean it's probably two
it's probably the towers it it's kind of
a lowkey yeah the battle Helm Deep
that's a crazy War though walking trees
big [__] trees Tak forever yeah it
does they are journeying a
while watching the extended edition bro
5 hours sign me up it's pretty long grab
me some [__] I'll go Lord Into The
Hobbit I think it's about 4 hours dude
the hobbits are kind of underrated
they're not as good clearly but they're
good yeah yeah but because they're done
later the graphics are a little bit
better bro the way that the camera is
cuz they shot with too many frames I
throw up watching the commercial
Dude too brutal like like a BBC show you
got to get more tough that was a little
soft I'm [__]
soft I can talk about you guys tell
you're talking about Pokemon and [__]
you seen Lord of the Rings no shot
that's like actually like Cinema like
for your little nerd ass cuz I like them
cuz they're dork [__] but he likes like
movies Lord of the Rings is a movie it's
a movie I like Game of Thrones isn't
that similar yeah so go watch Lord of
the Rings dude I knew a guy who had a
[__] ring ring and he put it on a
necklace and he walked around school
with it I was like damn dude this movie
is
gay so I could never get into L of the
Rings after that yeah CU you got to
bully him all that [__] was lame when we
were kids I went to like a weird school
so no one like made fun of us you know
but at a normal school if you were into
like Star Wars at my age yeah you're
getting beat up well if you had a
lightsaber you were still tight though n
dude say who bro no way I had the legit
replica ones I'm trying to go to
Disneyland right now get like the $300
one yeah that you're going to go make
the lightsaber [__] boy [__] soft ass
[__] [__] yeah it's going to be red I'm
on the dark side dude how how can you be
soft on the dark side have you seen it
have you seen the ceremony it is the
funniest [__] thing it is so
[__] I had a padle on braid for
a sec oh [__] you have The Robe it's
getting further and
further to leave hey have you have you
been to the lightsaber battles where
people do that [__] legit bro I had the
the pad braid like four years ago it
wasn't that long that was kind of hot I
might start working out just so I can
beat your
ass it's like a bully you like Harry
Potter though no I don't like Harry
Potter [__] that I'm way too cool for
for Harry Potter you got to like Star
Wars I love Star Wars I love Star Wars
but I don't like the new ones yo it's
hard to be a Star Wars fan nowadays
they're very all right are you watching
Ahsoka though Ahsoka is kind of dope
okay I heard the first three episodes
suck though uh they're all right but it
it finally feels like Star Wars again
what about Mandalorian Mandalorian is
pretty good though that's John fa it
doesn't feel Star Wars it feels like a
western it's good John favro is just
good yeah it's good but it doesn't feel
like Star Wars where shoka feels like
Star Wars that's why Clone Wars the
cartoon after the last Last Jedi I don't
give a [__] about Star War the old wait
was the old one 456 yeah yeah yeah
technically yeah 456 and one one two
three bro you go back and they're kind
of
good I think I think one completely
blows but two and three are cool Darth
Ma's fire Darth ma in the battle with
Quon Jin you know what we're talking
about it all I like Darth Maul Darth
Maul he has a red face right with all
the crazy lines that looks cool
I like I'd rather just watch the clips
on YouTube than watch the whole movie gu
cuz the fight scenes are pretty cool
great fighten the jarar shit's whack as
[__] I love jar I do too what about
padne dude Natalie Portman's hot she's
but she's also 15 you sick [__] in the
movie no shot oh Padme Padme is Natalie
Natalie Portman is it yeah you're sick
Natalie Portman is we were we were like
I was probably 15 15 Natalie's probably
my age right SI I have no idea she proba
30 I'm glad we're on a first name basis
yeah Natalie yeah pad Bay too oh yeah
it's not Queen amadala dude the white
pants in the second movie the white
pants Next Level George Lucas knew what
he was doing she gets a mid rff ripped
nobody's paying attention I me we can't
really talk about Hermione until the
last episode either but then she's
probably 18 we were young enough when we
were reading the books did you read the
books N I don't know how to read okay
you could tell she was hot in the
books it's like one of I was also 11
when Harry Potter was 11 yeah when the
books came out how old are you 37 yeah
I'm 35 yeah it was literally in our
generation we grew up was your I was too
old for that I watched it you say too
old like you're [__] geriatric dude
it was like a couple years off two years
is already a big difference in high
school but when the first book come out
we were like third grade you probably
like my mom has non-stop [__]
Buddhist sermons on her TV I never watch
that [__] could watch that it's about
witches bro it's right up the same it a
book would you get a wand at Universal I
never read n that's probably stretching
we at the end pay overpriced for a
[__] stick yeah but like the
lightsaber is kind of dope but I would
get a sword from The Lord of the Rings
oh I would love the lightsaber itself is
kind of dope but having to do the
[__] ceremony is the worst thing I've
ever SE as a grown man it probably feel
a little odd but you just got to shut
that part of your brain off you don't go
there in a cape and then act up a called
a robe Joe it's a robe it's probably a
lot I do like that [__] I knew guys that
were part of a saber group and they're
in their 50s and they like lar isn't
there a legitimate Club that does the
storm troopers though Storm Troopers are
sick if you have legit outfit no they do
and they're called like the 51st and
they're like a legitimate like Harley
Davidson style club I'm going to tell
you guys something that's going to make
you really mad right now Bart's never
even seen Star Wars and we went to Luca
Studios yeah that's so dumb we went to
yeah we saw the the what is it called
the industrial Light and Magic the ilm
special theater where they screen all
the movies before everyone else and we
met all the creators on Star Wars not M
just like he doesn't have any love for
thatted I was like this is very special
opportunity and a very unique and you
guys I wanted you guys to be jealous
R2D2 [__] greeted us when we came to
the lobby so you don't go through that
and they're like all right I should
probably go home and maybe like just try
Star Wars yeah well I turn it on and I
see [__] the new or it's not new but
then like Russell crows and Robin Hood
I'm going to watch that you going to
watch Robin Hood with Russell Crow
that's pretty good actually no way
that's that's not apples and oranges
though the only Rob that's not apples
and oranges bro yeah it is no it's not
one in [__] okay wow I'll Trust the r
apples and [__] dude [__] Russell Crow
except for Gladiator Gladiator Gladiator
GL Gladiator yeah of course dude that
Robin Hood movie suck dick dude there's
never been a good Robin Hood movie Men
and tights men and tights that's the
best yeah that's the only good one the
Kevin CER one's hilarious seen it '90s
yeah yeah I don't know if I've seen it
you see the guy Richie King Arthur no
you know kind of lame but I liked it oh
no you you never speak watch [__]
Star Wars or what yeah of course I like
guy Richie King Arthur thing it was kind
of lame but I was like I like it dude
Kevin Kus is doing this accent where
you're like I don't even know where the
[__] this guy's
from the best I watch guy Richie's
Covenant it's like his new movie you
guys watch it I like to eat F when I'm
sick that's crazy it just turned into a
gay ass Star
[Music]
Wars